here in los angeles covid vaccines are
being
slowly distributed to people 65
and older but according to a recent
article
some people under 65 in la
are still trying to get the vaccine at
any cost
these people are being called vaccine
chasers
yeah now typically these people line up
at vaccination sites for hours hoping
there might be an extra dose available
at the end of the day
not only that since this is la
some of these people are going as far as
sending in audition tapes
to be considered for early vaccination
yeah we actually got our hands on some
of these vaccine
audition tapes yeah unbelievable check
them out
hi jocelyn marks stewart talent and i am
auditioning to get a vaccine
hi i'm jeff matthews and i'm auditioning
for the vaccine with some of my
impressions
so you want the vaccine
you can't handle the vaccine
hi danny richardson sag eligible no i'm
not technically a doctor
i did play one once in a small adult
film
eli bright special skill stand up comedy
you know men and women get covered very
differently
so i actually brought some wigs uh
they're from my
improv studio before it burnt down oh
this one's cool
it's kind of like uh no you know what
i'm so sorry
sweet hi my name is barry diesel no
relation this is my first
video audition i am a stage combat
expert
proficient in such styles as punching
staff work
sword play
and throwing a banana in slow motion
hi i'm kathy yamamoto please give me the
back scene
i'm sorry sorry i am doing an audition
can you just keep it down
roommates and uh they let me keep the
lab coat which is
pretty great right also i will do nudity
[Music]
wow
white people take the vaccine like this